hey everyone how's it going my name is
may you go and on this channel we talk
about tech stuff and today we're going
to be talking about how to debug bugs
are still one of the most frustrating
things to encounter what I'm coding
because there's nothing quite like
building something that you think will
work only to have it just break in front
of your face but I also think that
fixing bugs is one of the most rewarding
experiences too because there's also
nothing quite like fixing a nasty bug
that you feel working on for hours only
to see it melt away at your fingertips
computer scientist Edsger Dijkstra once
said if debugging is a process of
removing software bugs then programming
must be the process of putting them in
it's pretty snarky if you ask me
Dijkstra but I agree with the essence of
it that most programs are not without
bugs it's really tough to know every
scenario and state that your code will
be run in when you're writing it so bugs
are a totally natural side-effect for
while you're writing code unfortunately
that doesn't make it any less
frustrating to deal with those bugs
especially if they're show-stopping bugs
that completely break what you're making
but there are definitely skills and
methods in debugging that help make the
process go a little smoother as I
mentioned in my computer science degree
video I was lucky enough to take a class
about how to debug as part of the course
curriculum and so today I'm going to
share with you five of my tips on how to
debug easily a lot of these tips come
from the textbook that we use for that
class which is this one debugging the
nine indispensable rules for finding
even the most elusive software and
hardware problems by David J Agins I
synthesize my takeaways from that book
along with my own experiences of
debugging for the last ten years so I
hope you enjoy and let's get started
tip number one is to reproduce the
behavior consistently reliably
reproducing bugs is half the battle a
bug has a much better chance of being
identified and fixed if you can
reproduce it the same way every time so
when you identify a bug don't even think
about the code that might be having the
issue just think of the code is a black
box and figure out what inputs caused
the bug to appear once you're able to
reproduce
sit one thing that I like to do is to
shorten the steps it takes to reproduce
it aka what's like the simplest thing
that I could do to make the bug appear
this helps them with the variables when
you're trying to fix the bug so simplify
simplify and simplify and once you're
able to reproduce it write down the
steps on how you do that especially if
there are a lot of them I mean if you
have terrible remember you like me
you'll be very glad that you did in case
that you forget how to make it appear
step two is to divide and conquer so
given that you're able to reproduce the
bug consistently we now have to figure
out which part of the code causes the
error this is where you're gonna try to
narrow into one part of the code I think
that 1 to 5 lines is about the level of
accuracy that we're trying to go for so
where do you start well depending on the
code base and your level of fluency with
it
you might know right away but in case
you don't hear the ways that I like to
go through the code the first is to find
any strings that you can search on for
instance there's a string literal in the
UI or maybe the error message is unique
I like to do search in that entire code
base with that term just to get a sense
of what neighborhood to look in and if
we're working on a code base with other
people this is a really great time to
ask them where to look trust me doing
this will save a lot of time and lastly
set breakpoints and print statements
this is especially helpful if you've
already narrowed it down to a general
area of the code base set breakpoints
and place print statements in different
parts of that area to get a snapshot of
values and states that can give you a
better idea of where the bug could be
the next tip is to survey the landscape
after you've been able to narrow into a
general area of a code base and I really
recommend doing this this part doesn't
need to take long but getting a thorough
understanding of what the code is doing
allows you to make a well-informed
change so that you're not causing more
bugs as you go about fixing it so make
sure to read the code carefully figure
out answers to questions like why was it
written like this when does the code get
run who wrote this code and what was it
written for in the first place oh and if
there was an error message
read that very carefully - and question
your assumptions maybe you're making
some assumptions about the code that
aren't necessarily true another thing
that I like to do is to pin the timeline
by looking at various paper trails like
what changes since the last time it
worked or look at your version control
history this point you're basically
acting as a detective for what went
wrong Jake Peralta taught me anything
about being a detective it's about doing
a little bit of roleplay when you're
doing some debugging work the role that
you're trying to play is to think like a
computer
what's the computer working with what I
use is it holding and what instructions
did you give it and one of the
foundational skills that will allow you
to do this is to think logically and our
sponsor for today's video
brilliant has courses to help you hone
those skills their website that have a
bunch of courses on the sciences
including one about logic all their
courses are interactive and easy to
understand and teach you how to think
logic is such a foundational skill for
all things computer science and software
engineering so make sure to check out
that course so go to brilliant dot org
slash hello my you go and sign up for
free and the first 200 people to go to
that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription thank you so much
brilliant for sponsoring and let's get
back to the video okay now it's it from
when you're fixing the bug make changes
one step at a time and this is because
bugs are delicate things changing too
many things at a time is not gonna help
you pinpoint what the issue really was
so literally just like change one thing
and then run the program if you need to
you and see how the books changed or if
it's fixed and one thing that's really
helped me in doing this is to create a
code sandbox if possible and what I mean
by that is to see if I can replicate the
same bug by pulling that part of the
code into something simpler so maybe
that's a standalone program or an app or
a class or whatever makes sense for your
environment but basically gets rid of
all of the other variables this helps me
to concentrate on that part of the code
only and makes it also easier to only
one thing at a time by getting rid of
all of the other distractions and if all
else fails my last hit for debugging is
to get a fresh perspective because
sometimes you just spend so much time
and gross in a bug that you don't know
what's up or down anymore it's actually
really important to recognize when
you're in the state in fact I usually
time box all of my bugs to one day as in
I will spend one whole day looking at a
bug and if I can't fix it then I have to
change tactics so ask a friend or
colleague to debug with you they have a
fresh set of eyes so they help to
introduce you to new perspectives or new
methods of problem-solving that maybe
you hadn't considered before and I know
it's tough but don't be afraid to ask
for help here
teens are stronger when everyone can
work to fix problems together whatever
lesson that you take away from this bug
can be shared with somebody else and
while it might take some more time to
fix the bug at the end of the day you
were unblocked and you can move on with
your life and in case you're working
alone sometimes it can just help to
think out loud to something so that you
can think more clearly about what's
going on anyway those are my five steps
for how to debug easily like I mentioned
I learned a lot of these skills in that
class I took in college the textbook
that we use for that class was super
useful and served as a blueprint for
this video so I'll leave a link to this
book in the description box down below
so thanks so much for watching my video
make sure to hit the subscribe button
for more videos about tech career and
lifestyle leave a comment down below for
any debugging tricks you have of your
own and I will see you next time bye